what's this math hat talking about
hey what's up guys this is kyler from
stanford texas i got a king extinguisher
for y'all
homemade christmas gifts
let me know what y'all think gang gang
buzz you got a skill like that
king it all day if you're handy with
them tools
make it make it bro but if you're not
like i don't want theo to give me some
[ __ ] stuffed hamster for christmas
you know what i'm saying
i need that real gift from theo but if
you got some skills
build that [ __ ] nothing better son
something you can't buy in the store
that'd be sick look i commend what
you're doing there brother because i'm
saying this especially at a time when
every
there's only seven companies left man
there's like delta airlines
amazon hibachi tesla jimmy john
tesla that's it so uh
you know to be doing something unique
that's going to speak
volumes if you really can make something
legit i love it look i get a little
climbing wall there for your son
and that's dangerous if it's a if it's a
crib if you still have a crib child
because you don't want them teaching to
sneak out you know they get bit by a rat
or something like on that um
that cartoon but it's all about right
now remember
i don't think that's it that's that
that's that you know man
[ __ ] build that build that climbing
ladder you got that rei son
you know what i'm saying that's true i
mean
i just think it's dangerous if it's
still a crib child brendan
[ __ ] child you know getting out at
night getting into your [ __ ] stealing
um what else dude oh i was gonna say
this
i remember i made my sister a baby crib
when we were
children and some kid had some wood
these born again christians around the
corner from us had a little bit of
extra wood so i went over there every
day man before christmas and just
i was like in there tinkering and
tottering and doing this and that
and i made it for and i got it over
there christmas morning she opened it up
and
she got she got in it bro and literally
got splinters in her whole body i hadn't
sanded it that's what i'm talking about
i don't want those gifts from you that's
not your skill set son you have a
different skill set i don't want you
building [ __ ]
also by extra wood you mean the kkk
members behind your house
is what you talking about with extra
wood
these guys were religion only bro they
had no yeah whatever brother
these guys were looking for the lord no
matter what color he was ain't nobody
buying that
dude i'm serious man yeah maybe your
sister didn't like
maybe your sister didn't like her crib
because it smelled like gasoline
maybe because it was made out of old
pieces of burning crosses that's why
but no i didn't remember she got it
maybe because they smell like gasoline
is covered in white sheets
she couldn't get out bro because she got
so many splinters right after she got in
oh it was horrible man but uh yeah dude
king it king it if you have a good
skill set bro yeah nothing looks dope
shout out to that dad
dad of the year there man yeah there's
something value about
you know you're gonna be one of the only
people doing that everybody i'm not even
joking when i went to shop there's only
like
four places just it's just like it's all
getting so narrow so to be doing
something creative
man sky's the limit start with one for
your kid make one for the neighbor kid
my dad got me a um wagon wheel when i
was young when my dad was born they
didn't have cars
so when he was a teenager they didn't
have cars and he actually had a wagon oh
[ __ ]
and he had a wagon from um
his uncle had a used to make wagons he
used to made
made handmade wagons and he actually had
a wagon wheel that he gave me one time
was autographed by his uncle
and it was dope so
um it was good man [ __ ] all that noise
that that red flyer that real [ __ ]
not that some your uncle made in his
backyard had that real [ __ ] red flyer
son the red [ __ ] tin wagon my brother
came
around in it i'd fall out every now and
then
and your brother's still carrying you
around son hell yeah
my brother built like dana white what
else you got nick
the people agree 59 say king it's the
king